[Music]
foreign
you've been on my mind recently no just
keep popping up in my dreams you don't
do anything you're just there
so this specific person the remarkable
nobody I'm also had that experience do
you have a picture
thank you
have you been dreaming about me have
I've been dreaming about you yeah
there's like a hundred messages somebody
wants to interview me
wait a minute and think before you do
anything drastic
why me uh
I don't know I'm special I guess
[Applause]
probably go viral who's actually had a
dream about me
to the way
[Music]
he was killing me Paul I'm going to have
nightmares I wish I was the one people
were dreaming about me too yeah no it's
it's something how's he dealing with all
this we're not even the type of people
that like attention you know you think
other people are seeing you naked
I hope I'm behaving through your dreams
Oh no you're not so I'm finally cool huh
I didn't say that you hear that Janet
she's saying I'm a cool dad
I really feel like you're playing with
fire here
I'm not actually doing anything to them
[Music]
you know Fame can come with some less
desirable side effects you should n't
prepare for that maybe we should cool
this thing off what what do you mean
it's embarrassing which part
[Music]
I guess I'll see you in my dreams
so of course not
I think